for my parents to now see me as an actor
getting a part on this show you know has
just been everything so I gotta keep
doing it Matt because you know we're
touching lives and making a difference
yes Ellen Pompeo fights back tears as
she reflects on her role as dr. Meredith
Grey
Kenny cheek and her sisters the actress
opens up on The Ellen DeGeneres Show
about how the beloved medical drama
Grey's Anatomy remains so important to
her and fans everywhere I go whether
it's Italy whether it's France London
Kansas the people that come up to me
with tears in their eyes and tell me how
meaningful the show is to them you know
the episode the last episode that I
directed was the first episode I
directed actually it was a teenager was
in the show and he was gay and he played
a gay character on my show and after we
had filmed the whole entire episode he
said to me you know my whole life I've
watched the show with my parents and
I've sort of used the show as a way to
tell my parents that I was gay and to
show my parents that it's okay that I'm
not different there's nothing wrong with
me and Grey's really helped my parents
to understand what having a gay son
meant and that it wasn't necessarily a
bad thing
we are really really touching people's
lives you know I see the effects of it
every day I hear the stories earlier
this month
eet's he caught up with Ellen where she
shared when she thinks they will end one
of TV's longest-running shows how will
you in Shonda would like know when it's
time to actually close this chapter
close this book I think the fans will
let us know really yeah yeah when the
numbers start to drop and no one's you
know people aren't watching the same
people aren't as passionate about it
it's time to call it there's no point
you were supposed to be here in 20
minutes not an hour and a half we had a
chance he had a freaking chance
what when you meet people you know that
that are going through things in their
life and they say that the show brings
them solace the show brings them comfort
whether they have cancer whether they're
an abuse victim whether they're in a
marginalized community and the show
gives them some sort of brings them some
sort of comfort to know that you're
really touching people even if it is
just a silly soap opera to know that
you're really touching people and making
people feel better even if it's just
because they're crying you know it's
meaningful and I think as an actor what
we want to do is tell stories and have
those stories reach people right as for
the future of grace the 48 year old star
confirm there's at least one more season
will there be a sixteenth season yes of
course I thought that there was a
probability that it wasn't well my
contract is till season 16 and so I'm
completely obligated to do season 16 and
you know these numbers there's just no
end in sight with streaming and the show
is so popular
you